hey everyone I'm ray from the stadia
team I'm here today to give you a brief
update on stadia the new generation
gaming platform where you can buy the
games you want and play them across your
favorite screens we're also going to
reveal more games that you'll be able to
play on stadia starting this November
instead of needing to buy a console to
play your games we give you access to
Google's powerful custom data centers
our servers are designed with today's
most demanding games in mind to ensure
your games run up the highest graphical
settings and frame rate available today
you can just fire up stadia to play your
games on your TV desktop laptop and
select tablets and smartphones with
stadia you get 4k gameplay without
annoying game downloads patches installs
or expensive gaming hardware to buy the
days of waiting to download and update a
new game are over just grab your
controller and you're in to play stadia
you'll need the stadia founders Edition
which you can pre-order today for only
129 it comes with three months of stadia
pro our premium subscription for you and
a friend a stadia controller and a
chromecast ultra to play on the biggest
screen in your home and as an added
bonus founders will already have the
full destiny to experience in their
stadia library ready to play from day
one we've had a fantastic response so
far and are almost sold out of founders
edition in some countries so if you want
to be one of the very first gamers on
stadia later this year you'll need to
get your founders Edition quickly in our
last stadia connect we showed you a
collection of launch titles coming to
stadia from the best publishers and
developers in the world and we keep
adding more games to the stadia catalog
whether you're looking for a
mythological storybook adventure in gods
and monsters or a chance to take back
London with a team of specialists in
watchdogs Legion Ubisoft has you covered
with both games coming to stadia so
let's get to it I'm going to pass it off
to my friend Shauna another member of
the stadia team who will run you through
some more big names to add to that list
hi I'm Shauna and I'm excited to share
the latest titles were adding to the
stadium portfolio my team and I have
been travelling all over the world for
years we've a meeting with the best
developers and publishers
with the goal of bringing more of your
favorite games to studia we've been to
Japan
England Germany the US Canada and most
recently Poland
our first video is with CD Projekt RED
who are making one of the most
anticipated games of 2020 and it's
coming to Cydia let's take a look if you
replace your body with a machine are you
still human
is it possible to maintain individualism
without any human parts maybe that
individualism is actually what creates
Humanity in us
see dpr has always been a company that
put a very big emphasis on the story
storytelling and creating very strong
emotion and players with cyberpunk we're
adding a whole new sort of pillar to it
which is what we call open-ended
gameplay we have non-linearity and
storytelling non-linearity and the way
you explore the world and now we want to
introduce non-linearity in gameplay you
can play your character any way we would
like to play it I like to complete
missions in a way that I have managed to
outsmart my opponents it no matter what
game it is I always play big butch
characters that kind of pull out through
everything and all these things have an
effect on how your story plays out
Chinese sovereignty good morning night
Sita the song on the radio is by rocker
boy Johnny silver Johnny silver Han
who's a legend and Knight City a
musician but also an activist we were
creating this character as we were in
the process we realized hey would be
really cool if Keanu Reeves could play
this character piano is amazing
Johnny silver handle will be our
player's guide to the cities with you
for most of the game wake up Samurai
we have a city to burn this project is
of a scale that we've never tackled
before the ambition is crazy
something like stadia really allows more
people to experience our stories
everyone gets to experience the same
awesome story quest and locations it's a
very technologically demanding game but
with the stadia you can actually play it
respectively or the power of your
devices there are many things that
people are gonna have very strong
feelings about I hope that the lens of
the game and the lens of the future will
show them in an exaggerated way things
that are already happening in our
society and hopefully our future is
gonna be better than the grim future of
cyberpunk 2077
[Music]
whoa easy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank CD Projekt RED for a look at the
breathtaking cyberpunk 2077 I can't wait
to have cyberpunk with me on stadia
wherever I go in our last connect we
revealed destiny - shadow keep to the
world we're happy to have our friends at
Bungie back to show you more from the
next chapter of destiny - story
something wicked has awakened nightmares
plagued our galaxy or past confronts you
Guardian end to it
[Music]
[Music]
you haven't seen darkness
[Music]
[Music]
a great battle approaches a trio of
adorable machines decide to follow their
hearts and form a band help them chase
their dreams in the upcoming 3d puzzle
platformer kind
[Music]
up next is Darksiders Genesis a
brand-new take on a beloved adventure
franchise
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for our next deeper look at a new
exclusive game coming to Cydia the
talented team at robot entertainment are
here to introduce you to the next
installment of their popular franchise
Orcs Must Die
[Music]
well well well take a look at these two
apprentices these kids are doing great
maybe a few tips from old max without
first that bad boy see gonna move him
slightly left over the right 17 degrees
and then also never by just make him go
poop
[Music]
holy cow that's I'm not gonna mass but
that's like a billion is this even legal
whoa whoa whoa the sorceress teach them
that
okay baby you're quicker learners than I
thought
don't worry
alright heroes you know what to do
heroes got a hero
orcs mercy must die three
[Music]
it looks very insurmountable a 500 mob
army you can't win
my name is Jerome Jones I'm the design
director here at robot entertainment we
really just want to make games that
people want to play and share with their
friends my name is Patrick Hudson and
I'm the CEO of robot entertainment when
you're making an interactive experience
you know it's going to end up in
somebody's hands and you want them to
feel something you want to connect with
that player that matters that means
something to us I always tell people
that Orcs Must Die is a puzzle game each
level is a puzzle you're a hero
you're trying to stop a bunch of bad
guys from getting into your house we get
a lot of letters you know but you guys
make oh um b3 already just make om d3
give us what we want so we're doing it I
think from works most i3 fans can expect
more of everything they love it's just a
bigger setting the physics are over the
top and so that just creates a really
fun landscape for for mayhem and work
destruction we were invited to check out
stadia back in January of 2018 Google
hand vez the controllers and allowed us
to play an earlier version of doom
running on stadia and it was great you
know right away it was a fantastic
experience and you know I immediately
saw it as the next transformative
platform coming to the industry kind of
the same feeling I got when I saw the
iPhone coming and what I thought that
might mean for games we knew that we
wanted to be a part of it we noticed the
difference when we started actually
playing the build on Stadium
that's what everyone's going to
yeah they're not gonna be subject to the
power of their machine everybody gets
that same massive power that's a big
deal that's a big deal I have always
wanted orc scenarios to feel like you
can't win always in the war scenarios
now you're gonna have a 500 mob army in
one single wave and that's not like
spread out
cleverly like 50 guys here 50 guys here
50 that's 500 orcs
that's what stadium made possible you
know you get to this point you want
people to start experiencing it
[Music]
after 25 years
a classic returns get set for
Windjammers to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
let's take a look at the exciting remake
of a cult classic destroy all humans
from THQ Nordic
hello friends
have you ever gazed up into the night
sky and wondered at the possibility of
life on other planets
mirthless fields might exist out there
hands extended in friendship awaiting
the moment when we humans take our first
tentative steps into space what tales
will be told of that glorious day when
we are first contacted by our brothers
from beyond the stars
[Music]
next our friends from Warner Brothers
are going to tell you about how one of
their biggest franchises will be
reimagined on stadia hey my name is
Aaron people Gerdes and I'm the
executive producer for Mortal Kombat
we're known for our solid gameplay our
quick brutal action and our over-the-top
finishing moves like our fatalities part
of the reason that people return to us
over and over is our in-depth story mode
these are characters that people have
grown up with they know they love and
will combat 11 picks up right where
Mortal Kombat X left off you're gonna
see a lot of returning fan favorite
characters as well as some new ones a
new era we've also got a time-traveling
element to the story so you'll get to
see some past versions present versions
and even some future versions of these
favorite characters it wouldn't be a
mortal kombat if we didn't have
fatalities and with Mortal Kombat 11
we've got some of the most brutal and
over-the-top that we've ever produced
making great fighting games starts with
the combat it's got to be fluid it's got
to be fast it has to be precise players
spend hours practicing the moves to get
that timing just right what really
convinced us to bring Mortal Kombat to
stadia was seeing the fast fluid
gameplay replicated on the platform the
game like ours that's very important to
us we have a certain quality bar that we
have to maintain and with stadia we feel
we can achieve that since the beginning
of development of Moral combat for
stadia Google has been with us all along
the way they've been a great partner to
help us make sure that we're achieving
the quality that we expect of our game
and that the players expect as well
one of the reasons we're excited about
the stadia platforming being available
on the cloud is just the ease of access
for our players
it is exciting it is legitimately cool
to be able to pause the game and then go
to your phone and play it on the phone
that's pretty cool
we're very excited to bring Mortal
Kombat to stadia this November thanks to
Warner Brothers and NetherRealm Studios
for this look inside their creative
process we're honored to be a new home
for one of gaming's premier franchises
when the world only moves when you move
things get really weird really fast
immerse yourself in the stylish action
of superhot
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you cater you meet us to discolor
[Music]
were you are [ __ ] up
[Music]
we can't wait for you to play great on
stadia let's have a look
[Music]
this next one comes from our friends at
eid software one of the fastest and most
visceral shooters of the decade is
headed to stadia what do you interfere
with now you speaker
they are no longer your people for Save
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we're mean on the cornea well known you
got it all worked up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
- at the suti even an kannada suman I
know you did but I cannot have a machine
or this
[Music]
the vast continent of Tamriel awaits
were thrilled to welcome a stunning and
vibrant MMO to stadia
fire and fury filled the sky over
elsewhere as ancient powers returned
ravage our world
[Music]
my calls heroes an adventuress
[Music]
rides and fire season of the Dragon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so happy to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
together
[Music]
how is the
[Music]
[Music]
a little mayhem keeps life interesting
and nobody does mayhem like gearbox and
now from our partners at Ubisoft a new
trailer for a game we know you can't
wait to play
[Applause]
as you can see London's having a rough
time of it what with these nasty
opportunists seizing control that's
where you come in we'll come to the
resistance it's up to you to build a
perfect team and take the city back the
good news is that any Londoner could
become your next recruit you can play as
anyone and they've all got their own
gameplay skills see this charming
chappie let's Victor what he only takes
off the amount of damage after his neck
2.04 chop man
and her that suit top-notch lawyer once
in your team she can get your operatives
out of jail automatically you don't even
need to lift a finger
nice one sue and this is Alan old codger
and veritable mad bastard increased
damage with rifles and weight may die
randomly r.i.p Ellen moving on everyone
is different so you have to decide
what's best for your team but why would
these fine people want to join you
well everyone's got an origin story help
them with their problem and once they
trust you they will become playable
characters each one of your new best
friends is a unique gameplay build so
dust off your sorting hat and give them
a class then level them up and unlock
new perks
there are thousands of possibilities
whether you've got a net for gizmos
[Music]
all you'd rather stalk people from the
shadows
building a team with diverse skills will
be critical to your success each new
recruit will make your team stronger you
can even customize your team members
their lovely heads of course accidents
can happen don't worry if you're small
you could always surrender no shame in
that
anyone got Sue's number luckily our city
is filled with millions of people and
any single one of them could be your
next recruit
[Music]
London's calling get out there and take
it
[Music]
thanks for joining us today as we move
closer to launch in November we're
continuing to add games to the city of
portfolio we look forward to sharing
more with you in the next studio konnekt